I'm needed now hello and welcome once
again to Android developer office hours
my name is Joel melon and with me today
are Alex Lucas rich Volker and Trevor
John's and Bruno Oliveira yes is ah with
us via there he is in Brazil via the
miracle of electronics let's go right to
our questions from google mom moderator
the top one today is when will the
action bar be available in the support
library and how to code if I want to use
map fragment what is the dirty trick all
right um I'll take the first question
there because that's that's how I showed
my plate so I'm the one to blame for not
being launched yet the answer is we're
working on it we're trying to get it out
to all developers as quickly as possible
there is still some work that needs to
be done on it so we will push it out
live as soon as it's ready so patience
hopefully soon okay does anybody else
have a comment on the second part on my
question is I i work with matthew and so
my question is are you trying to use map
view and a fragment or are you trying to
use a map fragment um can i it's really
difficult to tell what's going on right
now the only thing that we support is
what's called the map view view which
requires you to extend your activity
with a class called map activity so
fragments are not supported with the
android api from apps that she isn't
very i want us never actually is a is
there a map fragment or not we never we
never did publish you're not pregnant
we um the weather is very nice outside
yeah yeah yeah I don't think there is a
map fragment right now so yeah what
actually is right now that I remember so
some tricks we've recommended people in
the past is to go and create a
transparent activity like a pop-up and
you have a button and when you push that
button pop up your map in that
transparent activity and that will let
you go and display a map without having
it to consume the entire available
screen space it'll still be a layer on
top of your existing fragments and it
does it is a modal experience but it can
try and help preserve the tablet feel in
the absence of a way to go and place a
map view inside of a fragment so that's
one approach of course you can also go
and have a link directly to maps or just
have a standalone map activity and you
know a desire on that but that you will
have to be a little bit creative in how
you display maps for now ok thank you
nothing in the Hangout so let's move to
the next question a moderator is there
anyway so when a notification is clicked
a new task isn't started if the user is
on the Destin ated activity single top
flag or something similar doesn't seem
to work here that's a good question
actually I was hoping somebody from the
UI team would know but I'm not hearing
anything from any Ross in the room so
i'm guessing nobody here actually knows
the answer this one right well i can i
can venture on some observations here um
there's nothing wrong with going back to
the same task although you can get into
trouble that way that the issue is not
whether you go to a new tongue or the
same task the issue is how you construct
the back stack for the task that you go
to because if you're not careful on
you'll screw up the users navigation
experience in general we prefer that
when the
user clicks a notification you start a
new task even if they're going to the
same activity on so that they can
navigate correctly in all situations and
this is explained more clearly hmm this
is explained pretty well in the current
documentation for notifications in the
API guide so um in general we don't want
it on use the same task over again
because going backwards from it would
cause the user to go to a different
place than what they expected and that's
documented in the current documentation
yes that's a good point also I was doing
some testing I want to go here on my on
my tablet and let's take gmail as an
example so if you have a gmail
notification in your notification bar
and then you switch into gmail it
removes that notification so you might
want to consider whether it's even
appropriate to still have that
notification present when the user is
already inside of your life I think
actually pretty much all of this new
maps work that way I think talk does the
same thing I mean it makes a lot of
sense the idea of FDI notification is if
the user somewhere else you want to
bring them into your app if they're
already inside of your app it might make
sense to use a notification mechanism
that's actually part of your application
itself and then hide the system if
occations it's a little awkward to go
and you have to pull down the bar in the
navigation bar when you're already
present so maybe just taking a step back
from the code now just looking at your
UI design it might not be the best
option to keep that notification there
um yeah I think that what the original
poster is saying is that um he or she
wants to be able to have the user click
on an of notification and go back to the
activity um if the activity that the
that should be gone to the destination
activity is already on the users already
in that destination activity that they
don't create a new task right
the background but you ever get to the
foreground or if the the destination
activity is in the foreground and the
alert comes up Ron my argument is that
if it is in the foreground you shouldn't
even have that notification to begin
with ah there's a Gilman yes go ahead so
there I mean which I agree I think it's
pretty rare that you would need to call
on that location for all your in your
application already there can be a
couple of occasions where that makes
some sense and if your app it maintains
a variety of parallel context talk could
actually be a good example where I could
be in one chat but I might wish to still
be notified about activity that's
happening in a different chat that isn't
for grams so there are occasions where
you can call that word but I think the
general guidance have been given of you
know you want to come Holy recreate that
test stat upon that switches it's
completely appropriate right I can see
some situations in which the
notification would be issued by a
background service while the user was in
an activity that works in conjunction
with that service okay again you know we
actually just lost our junior miners
right okay cool so yeah I think that so
we all have to be from the market team
here so I don't think any of us can
actually say where the office has been
considered signing is certainly an issue
there are ways that in theory can be
worked around for example signing each
individual package but it would require
some pretty substantial architectural
modifications to the way the APK format
works so I'll just say that that's
really good feedback will make sure that
the team hears about it and if they
haven't considered it will let them know
but as far as whether or not we actually
have or not I don't think anybody here
is actually qualified answer that but
thank you for the feature quest it is a
good one I like it
thank you okay thank you
and one
Oh
yeah I can sweep the mountain it was
changed partly in response to user
feedback and some of the testing and
just kind of use of the product that we
went through well one observation we had
is that when users kind of learned that
behavior I've tapping the individual
icons in some cases they did not learn
kind of that there was also so it became
actually more laborious for those types
of users have to press through each of
those icons and sequence with each of
those notifications and sequence with
discrete touches and we also were little
concerned about the scalability how many
of those icons we could present in
general we just kind of in ICS we did a
lot of
tablet experience more direct more
consistent and I guess I would further
add that with some of the new
notification behaviors that we've
introduced in jelly bean with kind of
expandable and compatible notifications
and it's all the more reason to kind of
drive users to a single location and
where they can reveal where they can
open up we can present the most
important notifications in a more
expanded fashion and we're doing more in
terms of can organizing that set in a
really more meaningful way for the user
so rather than have a variety of kind of
small context that these are we go to we
just drive the user towards one
centralized location for managing
notifications okay so it's for those of
you who aren't aren't sitting on stage
we just lost Joe's Mike here so we're
trying to figure out going on with that
if ya see you're getting a little
battery light yes yes all right we have
any spare batteries yes we do I'll take
care of it while these people are
talking right join me to take the next
question um well about the answer about
device manufacturers and enabling this
yeah you can do is Mike for a second two
people can actually hear them there we
go sorry say that again oh I'm sorry so
um how about the question of device
manufacturers re enabling this feature
or doing this feature differently I
would I would advise against it and I
think it's the kind of thing that um
the devices to adhere to I think in
general the notification and kind of
status and system navigation or areas
are things where we expect you know as
close coherence as possible and yeah
that's not a hard no you can't do it but
I worry a little bit that kind of going
somewhere differently with that behavior
may kind of separates you from future
enhancements to the notification system
ok I think I have returned to the land
of living here we'll see what happens
actually I think you might push muted
for the loss that last sentence but yeah
I think I think that's Joe's Mike is
back now I'm back now ok I am good let
us proceed thank you rich sure um here's
an interesting one how can I normally
import API demos project into eclipse
when I've imported API demos sample a
pile of errors appears i've made project
clean added support library but no
result what is the problem in importing
projects to eclipse that's a good
question because it should work normally
the process for adding a demo for a she
city normal samples should work just
fine inside of API demos however each of
those you know what you've used
individual samples is actually just a
collection of classes if you try and add
you know one of the subfolders there's
no Android manifest you know there's the
layouts are in a top-level folder that's
not going to work so you can't just go
and take one of the subfolders strip it
out and expect it to build as a
standalone project now if you want you
can create a brand new project from
scratch copier classes in copy the
layout file in copy the resources files
in and if you do that you can get it to
build as a standalone project but API
demos wasn't designed with that in mind
it injury the first goal of API demos
honestly is actually to go and be our
sandbox for engineers to play with and
in addition it will also give you a file
level demonstration of how these things
work but it's really not designed to
work in standalone mode that's where the
rest of the samples this part of the
framework or this part of the SDK
come into play and that's yes sort of
those to intervene what goes into API
demos and what doesn't is this an issue
be standalone so the ears you're getting
is because you're trying to import
something that's not actually an Android
project if you go one level up import
just all of API demos as a whole that
should build and if it doesn't let us
know what area are getting and we can
look into a bit more but that should
work okay next question is how does
Google Plus achieve the horizontal
scrolling navigation when you turn your
phone into landscape mode excellent
question I can't tell you exactly how
Google Plus does it I suspect what they
do is they have something like a grid
view that they've modified to go and
support horizontal scrolling I believe
Alex I think you've looked into this in
the past correct yeah my understanding
is actually just what you said it's a
heavily modified grid view yeah so one
of the nice things about android is the
entire framework is open source if
there's some feature that you'd like in
one of the internal classes like good
view it's not there for example
horizontal scrolling it's entirely
possible just go and grab the source
code for that file and copy it into your
project and make your changes and then
you just be using your own local copy of
grid view of course we do want to
provide a framework that works as is
without needing to modify this stuff but
you know every now and then you do have
some advanced feature that that's beyond
what the framework designers had
intended when they designed the class
all right I think Joe lost his
microphone again so I'm going to go
ahead and read the next question so this
is from magma spawn in colorado springs
and the question is what things are
being addressed in terms of stability
Android versus iOS Apple developers make
apps that generally are made to run a
specified processor and ram and screen
size android is so developmental that
you risk stability doing so stability
equals slow and I'm just gonna say I
disagree with that entirely I think yes
okay yeah right yeah I mean other
platforms like iOS yo you there are less
device configurations to worry about but
this isn't anything new for developers
you know take a look at you know desktop
PCs right the user can go to adjust
their window size your devices with
different RAM you have you know
definitely more processor you know a
wider range of processor speeds than
you'll find on Android just because the
PC platforms been around for so long and
as a developer you have to take these
things into account now unlike the pc
platform we go and give you a lot of
tools to go and manage this you can use
things like you know filters to go and
make sure your device can't be installed
on platforms where you know doesn't work
we have a very robust layout system that
makes it very easy to go and handle
different screen sizes and different
densities and there's a lot of tools
here that you know I don't want to bash
iOS but we do provide a lot of tools
that they don't for handling different
screen sizes because it's something that
androids had to deal with some pretty
much the very beginning since android
1.6 to be specific so we've gone to
great lengths to go and make this easy
for developers yes it's an extra
consideration but the tools are there to
go and make your life you know to make
your life Pleasant while you do this to
end I don't think it flows close things
down if anything it's actually a benefit
to the Android ecosystem because it
means you have more devices out there
with more options OEMs are able to
innovate faster developers are able to
innovate faster on top of those features
and I think the end result is a much
better experience for end-users a much
better chance for developers so I think
I've been that to death but anybody else
have anything they want to add to that
um yeah I'm not really I have a question
about what's really meant here because
um stability to me suggests that in
every new version of Android that's
released there are a lot of bugs that
were introduced in that version yes yes
debility is a lot of different
definitions yeah it could be is it
bugginess api changes right I'm not
clear what you mean by stability I mean
as far as you know bugginess I I don't
think that's the case at all and android
on the whole is
the very stable especially especially
the things you're talking about here
like screens have something like that
and API changes you know again we had
one big API change back in 1.6 where we
headed support for multiple resolutions
but since then there hasn't been very
much this change there I mean we've
added additional functionality but we've
we've maintained backwards compatibility
all the way back to Android 10 right um
I think that the point here is maybe
that Apple developers make apps that
they can focus on one particular device
and Android varies because their new
devices coming out all the time and so
um you risk so-called stability because
you're writing for a device that you for
devices that you may not be aware of and
that so-called changes your app it
shouldn't and we try to make it so that
we provide tools that allow you to write
the same app for a variety of different
devices of different sizes ram sizes
screen sizes some um that would you mind
comment any others yeah one thing that
that is always a nice to point out is
that it's not 1,000 times the effort but
your app runs on 1,000 times the number
of devices so because Android is running
like 11 thousand devices so actually if
you think about desktop applications
every single best of that anyone has at
their home is a different device so into
though Android launches new devices
every now and then I mean it's not some
more death of them developing that
desktop applications so some people say
oh Android is fragmented i think it's
it's the the reverse and it's sort of
like etely answer to fragmentation
because we have very a very stable set
of tools and a very robust set of tools
to deal with device diversity so you can
talk about Android without talking about
diversity I mean diversity is one of
those core values that the platform
doesn't exist without right very good
point thank you Bruno and I know this
question is addressing kind of
coating the apps specifically but just
from a design standpoint it's part of it
is just kind of putting yourself in the
right mindset for kind of how you think
about a nap and how you think about a
device and I know the process that i go
through is like a UI designer and i sit
down to work on a new android
application is to really start kind of
at a very early stage start time
sketching that app in a variety of four
different scales you know I often kind
of work and a set of wireframes wearing
I'm thinking about you know even within
a device I'm thinking about a portrait
I'm thinking about landscape I'm
thinking about kind of the different
sizes of screen and the different sizes
of you know kind of three and a half
four and a half 7 10 inch displays and
how to kind of divide the tasks across
that and it is a it is a little bit more
work but I think it also kind of just
kind of conceiving of your app across
that kind of multiplicity of
presentations actually helps kind of
frame your thinking about what this app
is trying to be for the user different
context and I would imagine kind of a
lot of that same thinking women would
apply to how you actually architecting
the app right now I imagine a lot of
those same decisions or cleans that web
designers need to get with nowadays too
right yes I mean that's why things like
CSS media queries were invented so that
you can go and have your app you know
Grace Lee convert from something running
on a desktop device to a tablet to a
phone you notice the screens get smaller
your layout will just go and dynamically
adjust you know Android works the same
way and you know to answer your
questions to weather off this is slowing
things down or not I mean mote your
Android you look at all the growth in
Android in the last couple of years and
look at all the growth in the web over
the last two years yeah both of them
have you know have been developing an
extremely rapid pace so I really don't
think this is slowing things down either
a for developers or for the platform
okay um let's move on to the next
question what are the current options
for NFC developing and can it be
integrated with a compatible RFID device
example and NC foam communicating with
third-party RF I be chip and if C mag
stripe for some sort of identity on a
scent occation for an application all
right so first off you're using three
different terms here you have NFC which
is a specific technology within the
broader field of RFID rfid encompasses a
lot of devices and then on top of that
mag stripe is a completely separate
technology altogether right that that's
like near the strip on the back of your
credit card now that that's technology
from back in the early 80s or possibly
earlier cassette tapes right so and if
see the to answer your broader question
though can you use NFC with third-party
devices and the answer that is
absolutely so NFC is an open standard if
you search online for NFC forum you can
find the group that actually has
developed those standards thankfully is
a developer you typically don't have to
read them unless you're implementing new
hardware but any device that conforms to
the NFC spec is compatible with Android
so normally there's two modes that
you'll typically want to find yourself
working in you can do tagged emulation
which is you know say what if you find
by those at little NFC stickers online
that's tight emulation you can buy
third-party tag readers and transmit a
program tag that you clean your app from
your Android device to the tag reader
you can also do the opposite right you
can buy just like I said you can buy
stickers online that are tags program
program them you can even program them
with your android phone and read them
you could also appear to pure mode so
you can go and configure your NFC reader
writer to go and talk by directly with
the device and so that's how things like
Android Beam work and to give you an
example of in practice for Google i/o we
built something we call cake droid it's
a big you know kegerator with the giant
model Android on top with arms that
dispense beer it's pretty cool
we originally were going to go and use
NFC Timmy badges sadly that didn't work
out this year but we built an NFC reader
into it using an Arduino along with a
NFC prototyping kit that we bought from
sparkfun and it's using open-source
libraries to go and handle the NFC
communication and that were it works
just fine it works beautifully I'm sad
we didn't get a chance to demo that part
of it really well at i/o we did have
some sample badges there but it's
entirely possible there aren't any open
source libraries for Arduino that i
found that work in peer-to-peer mode
there's no reason you couldn't write
them but tag emulation is definitely
supported in the open source libraries
on top of that if you want to go even
further android does provide low level
access to the NSC hardware you can open
up a rock connection to whatever NFC
device you're speaking to and so if
you're using something that Android
doesn't have built-in support for but
still falls within one of the NFC specs
you can always go and write your own
your own library to go and handle the
protocol that way too so that's an
option I will add the NFC is a big field
there's a lot of different options out
there there's four different types of
standardized NFC tags type 1 2 3 and 4
as well as some more proprietary options
like me fair classic there's only
support on some devices so the caution I
just want to give you there be careful
what devices you're speaking to and what
protocol they use for the actual NFC
side of things my advice is stick to the
the technologies that are standardized
as part of the NFC forum so that that's
the type 1 2 3 and 4 tags and that way
you'll have the broadest compatibility
with Android devices you know me for
classic is the one in particular I want
to caution you against it works fine
with Android devices today but that's
because most of them use a NFC chip set
manufactured by nxp which is the
computed owns me fair so there are other
NFC companies out there that don't
support me for classic so just be
careful
okay that's a lot of information that
right um-hmm um how about this thing
about identity authentication for an
application communicating with it on NFC
something or other towed i dint have
identified something yet work yeah it
totally it work so I mean identity and
authorization is a pretty big field
there's a lot of different ways you can
do it most of the parallels from your
web programming applied here so they're
the easiest option is you can just go
and broadcast a static ID and have the
other end pick it up and that works fine
it's pretty easy to implement you could
just you do it as a normal n def payload
put your ID in there as an integer it
would work the thing you do have to
watch out there for though is NFC is a
radio based technology and it is
susceptible to east dropping and
potentially cloning if you do that and
so the answer that is to build
cryptography on top of that and so
that's how things like NFC enabled
credit cards work you go and do a
channel challenge response type exchange
or use something like RSA so you have a
private key inside of your phone and a
public key in your whatever you're
authenticating to and then your phone
would sign something like a time stamp
to prove that yes I own the private key
without ever actually broadcasting it
over there waves so totally possible you
know there it's just a matter of how you
want to implement it there's a lot of
resources out there on how to handle
this from the website of things I
definitely brush up on that if you
haven't already and literally it's no
different than opening a TCP socket to
some random server except rather than
doing it over IP you're doing it over
the NFC protocol thanks great answer
this question looks like it's
specifically for rich rich Fulcher
what's the reasoning behind the nexus s
keeping its 2.3 touch camera shutter
sounds on forex if it looks like whole
ocean it sound like cohle along song so
a good question I actually don't have a
specific answer for this unfortunately I
will take it back to the camera team but
but I did great yes that hollow as a
theme is
intended to merely be kind of the visual
cosmetic aspect of the device and but
it's also meant to cover that the entire
soundscape and all that all the beeps
and bloops that the device makes Arkham
part of that feel in that that overall
sensation that we're going for with
hollow so I will follow up on this
question sorry don't have specific
answer for you okay thank you I'm gonna
skip the next question because I'm not
really sure what it means perhaps we
have received our first spam developer
office hours and so we had two thousand
seven hundred sheep yeah really have to
go back that we're being directed to go
back to 2007 and I don't know why so
actually if that's a question then are
we in 2007 the answer is false eight
years 2012 oh I thought I was guy was
going to answer 42 but okay you know
false is also good on the question after
that is what practical damage can occur
if my activity handles the configuration
changes on retained non configuration
instance the doc state you must not rely
on it being called is this correct for
configuring change itself I'll take this
one okay okay so first of all on
retained on configuration instance is
actually deprecated so you don't have to
worry about whether or not it's being
called because you shouldn't really be
using it instead fragment now is a
method called cell retain incense and I
think it's called setting instance it's
set retain something the important part
is that what this does is it means that
the fragment will not be destroyed and
recreated across destruction of the
parent activity so anything that you
need to save between say device
rotations if you put in that fragment it
will still be there when the new
activity creates itself that's a button
thing to point out is that it's a on
retain instance actually a the set
retain instance is actually also
available in the app combat library so
that this means that it can also use it
before an econ oh great cool so that's
awesome that means it goes all the way
back to
far back do we depends on which one's
sin if it there is a v4 version of the
of the support library I don't know
whether this is probably four or one of
the later versions but if it's in before
it goes all the way back to go go
belowdecks I don't know that right yes
no not yeah to answer the first part of
what practical damage can occur if my
activity handles the configuration
changes basically to start lots and lots
of memory leaks if you're not destroying
all the things that shouldn't be around
anymore I'm sure there's all sorts of
side effects for things that you can't
destroy but it's that sort of falls
under the area of undefined behavior I
can't exactly we can't really provide a
list of you know top three things that
will go wrong but the easy way to do
this is just not to worry about any of
that stuff indices on retainer sorry use
the fragments set retain instance method
okay okay okay so we've got about five
minutes left but I want to take a moment
to remind viewers that if you're
watching live you are welcome to join us
on hang out and ask us questions live I
think we've made it through an entire
upside without any live questions even
though I see a full hang out over on
Daniel screen so for those of you guys
who are in the Hangout first off uh why
haven't you asked a question yet and
second off for those of you who have
questions and I haven't an hour feeling
of a child you know you're certainly
welcome to hop on and ask us questions
live we love to interim sex question
though would you guys yes pretty much
the only question in that all day hmm
yeah what do you guys who are if you're
in the hang on you know maybe why
make me maybe they've been satisfied
with all the great questions we've had
so far great job yeah it's actually this
question from filling actually didn't
seem any video but okay when this
question is looks like there's a problem
with manifest knee are ger I can
successfully package and install with
the debug key but when I try
on the app for deployment that classes
in the libraries of missing at runtime
is this something you guys at that is
okay what's the class name again they're
a class name said manifest manager any
manifest merger yeah this is not an
issue I've actually ever encountered aye
mere are all the source files in the
same project because what I have seen
before is if people import external jars
or external like shared libraries from
separate projects they get bundled into
a jar and sometimes depending on how the
way they access them proguard might
might sort of optimized away the classes
that it doesn't see being called within
within whatever project is being
compiled yeah nothing that can get you
in trouble too if you're using tools
like IntelliJ which go and look up
references inside the IDE for you they
have their own build path which is
sometimes separate from what the Android
build script uses for that reason many
dependencies you have should almost
invariably go into a Lib folder even if
you configure it in your IDE I still
recommend using a lid folder because
that's what a lot of the command line
tools expect to sort of a magic location
just like your resources and source on
top of the only exception there be no
library projects which of course will
live in a different form I think it's
libs right le BS palsy I can never even
for the most part lieb s I don't know
that that helps if you need any more
information you can always post a note
post something on stackoverflow and then
put a link to it in the notes for
moderators so that we can take a look at
it further on since we've got five
minutes left I'm going to move through
real quick here actually we have back
two minutes lawton ok so we've got two
minutes left uh-huh which is good for
this next question which is UX guests
what would you say are the top three
most common developer pitfalls related
to your eye out
that's an interesting question so maybe
I'll I guess I'll start by covering one
pitfall from the topic that I covered
which was kind of the up and back
navigation within Android and I think
the the biggest pitfall that we still
see even developers working within
Google falling prey to occasionally is
handling notifications and properly kind
of building out the back sec we had a
question about that at the start of the
hangout today and it was a change it was
a change that we introduced back in ICS
that we stuck with for jelly bean and
would change anything else for you but
it just be particularly careful when
handling that notifications get tricky
because they generally navigate you to a
screen deep within your applications
hierarchy and you need to kind of
properly construct a corresponding test
sack that so that back will behave
properly keeping you within the app and
navigating as expected and we go through
that in you know pretty pretty complete
detail in the session so you know feel
free to refer back to that and for the
other topics I guess a general topic
that came up is more of a philosophy
which is just be lazy be lazing the
sense of let the framework do as much
lifting for you as it can you know at
this point it is a a nicely mature
framework you can get support for action
bars for a lot of the components that
you would want to use in your
application you don't need to go custom
and we have a phrase that we use within
our design group here which is that we
want our designs to deviate with purpose
you know we try to use the standard
conventions wherever we can we kind of
it's good for you as the developer it's
good for the user and because it's the
expected behavior and it's not you
shouldn't change it it's when you make a
change make sure it's a very thoughtful
change that it's something that's really
meaningful and important for your
application and for stuff that isn't so
important just lean back on the what the
frame
provides you know don't they'll put your
heavy investment into having a very
custom setting screen use the preference
framework and to kind of build that out
easily and you won't have to kind of
revisit it as aggressively through
further versions of Android great thank
you rich John we seem to have reached
the end of our time with you today i
wanted to mention that i forgot to
mention I'm Daniel Pham who's our
engineer today Thank You Daniel um
otherwise we don't have anything left
for you today will wish you good luck
and happy programming and see you next
time yeah as always we're here every
Wednesday 2 p.m. pacific and yeah be
sure to check in advance submit your
questions moderator we usually puts the
moderator dare to advance and as always
be sure to join us for the live stream
so you can ask questions live right
thank you